i got onto the left hand wing
clambering over that door lip and then i
stood onto the wing
and was able to stand on the wing
momentarily i jumped
um i would estimate at a height of about
fifteen one five feet
[Music]
i can remember going to luton airport
back in the day and i was just a kid
and you could get quite close to the
activity you'd hear the
the pilots kind of doing the engine
tests and and throttling down the runway
down that center line and
the noise the smell of the uh the
kerosene coming off the back of the
aircraft and
you know the desire to perhaps uh learn
to fly
myself one day was perhaps born during
that time
i'd been with an instructor for about
three weeks duration
i had a couple of different instructors
during that time and everything was
going very well
and then i'd been solo for around about
eight days
it was one of those bluebird days you
know the sun was
was shining down on me you know birds in
the trees kind of twittering
and i was just thinking about what was
what was coming ahead as far as i was
concerned it was just another day solo
and i was kind of hour building
building up my experience and then i
would have been coming back to the uk
sort of job done sort of tick in the box
and that ambition complete
as it were nice and calm nice and gentle
hand on the stick
and then i go full throttle and i'm
starting to take off
and i'm starting to head higher
and then once i get to a thousand feet i
can pull back gently on the throttle and
sort of level off
so that the aircraft sort of goes from
climbing to sort of leveling off
a thousand feet and then i can kind of
gently kind of cruise around in the
pattern and do
and do what i need to do i then did a
look
and i did a look again because i
couldn't quite believe what i saw
i was struck by an immediate
vision if you will of a thin streak of
visible yellow
orange flame and i had to look again
because it was a
it was a shock initially and
and i realized that it was fire and it
was a thin
streak and it was emanating from the
front portion of the fuselage
and i looked down at my feet on the
rudder pedals
i could see flame starting to lap and
around the feet and the ankles
inside the the chamber of the small
two-seater cockpit that i'm sat in and i
thought immediately
christ this is no drill this is for real
this is an emergency
and i've got to get this aircraft down i
immediately felt
the heart sort of boom boom boom within
my chest
you know there i was a thousand feet
well nowhere to go where am i gonna go
you can't jump from that height
uh people have asked me you know did you
not have a parachute well you don't wear
a parachute in a
light aircraft i was under no illusion
if i didn't get out of that burning
cockpit quickly that um the likelihood
was i wasn't going to make it i was
going to be a goner
and that fire would would have certainly
overwhelmed me and um
and and and i wouldn't i wouldn't have
you know lived to tell the tale
the only option i foresaw was indeed to
to to try to to get out of that cockpit
early but i needed to get her
the aircraft that was to a safe level in
order to
to have any you know chance of of
pulling that off cleanly and make it
happen
my mind then flicked back to one of the
us
instructors and i can distinctly
remember it and he said
and i quote above all if there's an
emergency
and you've got a problem fly the damn
aircraft and these words kind of echoed
and reverberated
in in my in my memory and i and i
thought
i've got i've got to hold on i've got to
get a grip here and i've got to do
exactly that so i kept my left hand on
the
the flight control stick and my right
hand on the throttle and i carefully
just knocked off that power on the
throttle
to try to reduce air speed and i needed
to reduce that significantly
in order to get myself to a relatively
safe
speed approaching the active runway all
the time i'm watching the altimeter
spin down so through 900 feet
800 feet 700 feet 600 feet and i've got
that left hand on control
right hand on the throttle and i'm
trying to breathe and i'm trying to
think through it
and i'm just trying to really calm it
all down as much as possible
when i flew over the top of the active
runway i was literally 100 feet
50 feet by the time i'd cleared it
i turn off the key magnetos alpha bravo
the red switch is off
in the center column fuel pump off
rotate
fuel selector valve through 90 degrees
off everything
off off off in sequence the at the lower
at the lower reaches
from 50 feet and below
the fire was literally lapping my face
that hand on the control stick
the right hand on the throttle and i was
literally
in a vain bid if you will to protect my
airway from flame
ingress i then opened my left hand
canopy door
i can remember reaching across fiddling
with the um
the handle i then had to elbow it with
my left elbow
and punch it and strike it with the heel
of my hand
and i'm now 50 feet 40 feet
30 feet 20 feet all the time looking
checking looking and at 20 feet i got
onto the left hand
wing clambering over that door lip
and then i stood onto the wing and was
able to stand on the wing momentarily
but i had the backwash of the prop which
is why i have this uh
really aggressive sort of right side
dominant burn
and that affected my my scalp as you can
see my right shoulder
down the right hand side of my lower
limb my left side was was
significantly protected and that's uh
was burned but it's indeed a lot
healthier and
so i jumped i would estimate a height of
about 15 1-5
feet in reality i was probably
traversing about perhaps 30 knots
through the airspace and that height 15
feet so it was it was a tremendously
hard impact
even though i landed feet first i then
thrust forward i smashed my face
on the uh on the sharp florida
razor grass below and i remember my
right shoulder was still on fire so i
aggressively had to pat it out and my
right scalp i could sense it was still
on fire so i patted it out
the aircraft carried on on a very low
and shallow traject trajectory without
me
and i watched her crash land there was
this ugly
crumpling crashing noise
and extremely loud and and very scary
and all of a sudden boom an almighty
explosion
i felt the shock of the explosion the
energy
come through me and back again and that
sucked out
all of the air that i had within the
lung
and the heat and the inferno was
indescribable it was
intense and it was at that moment when
the pain
hit me for the very first time and the
only way i can describe that it was like
a tsunami
of pain that washed over me from head to
toe
every uh aspect of of nerve and sinew
was struck
by this pain and i i just cannot
describe
the intensity of that i had a facial
fracture so i inadvertently ruptured my
my uh my nose bone i had bilateral
super orbital eye socket fractures on
both sides from the impact
also the force from the jump and the
landing
uh traveled through my torso area little
did i realize that i'd
um ruptured my large intestine so the
colon and it also lacerated my liver
internally which was now hemorrhaging
and bleeding very profusely
internally i was 63 percent
third degree burns and that came to
light uh
later on with the um the medical
diagnosis
i'm starting to grow colder and weaker
with every
second that was passing so i then
decided that um
it wasn't going to be long that i didn't
have long uh to go
to to survive here so i then took my
shoes and socks off
i'm not even sure what the reason for
that was i just figured
um in my rationale that this was
clearly one journey that i didn't need
my shoes and socks for typical soldier
you know i wanted that order right to
the very end
and i lay the shoes and socks on the
right hand side
and i just put them neatly by the side
of me and
i held on and i don't know how i did it
all i can
suggest is that i was a young man at the
time you know i was just turned 32 years
of age
and i was as fit as a butcher's dog by
virtue of what i did for a living
uh you know with the forces and i kept
myself in in great shape
and so i i guess i had that fighting
edge but i still didn't have long
and i waited and and then i heard the
siren so i was like
and then the truth is um i don't
remember anything for
for realistically the next six months of
my life
the doctors in orlando gave me about
five percent probability of survival
which is extremely slim odds even though
they placed me in drug induced coma
i was in the fight of my life i mean
this was jamie hull
you know world war iii to give you an
indication
um thankfully because of the insurance
that i was backed up by
um the bill in america came to some 2.6
million us dollars and that was only for
around about four month period i had 62
operations under general anaesthetic
with a multitude of different surgeons
for all kinds of different
reconstructive work following
the burns and to get me back on track to
get me back to a semblance of
health and normality and indeed i had
many years of
work both physically and mentally in
order to
accept and in order to rehabilitate
myself
it was very important for me to get back
in the air somehow
and to fulfill that ambition
all over again and to uh to keep going i
did
fortunately uh um
win a scholarship to learn to fly a hot
air balloon
and i did my training in italy it gave
me that real sen
that sense of freedom admittedly you
know what i do with the balloon from
time to time is a lot more sedate
but then i guess the new version of
jamie hull is a lot more sedate
you know i'm not that high-speed guy
that i once was and so
it's probably quite fitting really
you